hey guys is dad's the founder think here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of true detective the
season finale but it's really like a
series finale ya series finale a form
and void because it's an anthology
series so this story ends true detective
as a TV show is going to continue but
this storyline is over so in essence
it's almost like a series finale um I
really liked it I think I think some
people will probably hate it and then
some people because some people are
looking for something else in this
series that that I don't think that this
show ever ever really said it was gonna
be like but I think some people were
thinking it was going to yeah to be more
like twisty and more like twin peaks
kind of like I mean I think people were
looking there's a lot of a lot of fan
fictions and coming out lately for this
a lot of conspiracy theorists and things
I think this is really about these two
detectives these I guess you could call
them broken Knights these guys finding
some measure of peace in their lives or
some measure of I guess you can call it
I was surprised I was like this is kind
of a happy oh it is the very idea you
know they're not in the context not like
hey life is perfect whoo but I mean it's
very optimistic and right I mean it's
just it's just it's such a good ending I
liked it that those guys actually found
hopeless social dark in the week I mean
child you know kids in microwaves being
burned you know little kids I don't know
what was her yeah it's always darkest
very dark bleak and in the character of
rust cohle played by Matthew McConaughey
is very nihilistic right but in the end
you kind of find out he actually isn't
that that's his like what's-his-face uh
Errol Childress the guy who ends up
being that the the me off your mat take
off your man like Ryan you really aren't
this nihilistic guy you're actually
secretly an optimist yeah I love that at
the end when he's I don't say he found
God or found out faith but he found he
felt that he believed in something more
than just life as a circle we just go
around the drain the drain just doing
the same thing he felt his daughters
presence wait
for him which is a cool i mean he he
found something to live for beyond you
know just like we're all here than we
die I mean he found some links would you
kind of know in a way even though he's
been talking all this nihilistic stuff
very bleak very dark where you have to
always wonder throughout this whole
series like okay if you really believe
that then why are you even trying to do
any good you know yeah like if life is
just life and it sucks right like why I
even attempt to do any good because in
our end it doesn't really YB detector
scoot yourself now and get it over with
exactly or just you know do something
else right yeah but deep deep down he's
actually an optimist you know he you
know with the whole story about the
stars tell him telling woody or like
Woody Harrelson telling her yeah hey
like it's actually election winning
likes winning cuz it started dark right
yeah it to me what it's really saying is
that yes there's a lot of darkness
around but you can't just do nothing
about it no and even if you know like in
the end they didn't come to they didn't
catch everyone right no especially the
rich guys like the godlike the senator
or whatever they these like yeah they
got the hillbilly guy either they have
the hillbilly get that there is some
sense of not one st. justice it is it's
we call you hold it like their victory
yeah or it's our way it's a win for us
it's not we didn't get everybody but we
got we did what we needed to do cuz Russ
always said like we have a debt we have
this obligation they did what they were
supposed to do yeah and what are you
supposed to do instead do nothing right
see that everybody do nothing then then
it's gonna be even worse so in the end
yeah Cole is kind of an optimist yeah I
mean it was a pleasant ending I mean and
then we look at let's look at heart I
think I think the thing is Chris Matthew
McConaughey's I'm such a good year of
ice called us in the Makana sonso he
still has interstellar coming out
Christopher Nolan in November I think
sometimes we forget that what he's doing
a great job in this role yeah he's
platonic I mean what he's been good for
four years we know what he's good but
he's doing a great job too and seeing
him at the end with his family I like
they said like how are you and he he's
like I'm I'm good like I think I'm
pretty
like he wasn't a hundred percent sure
was like yeah I'm doing all right I'm
good I mean he just did such a good job
I love that part when he checks on Russ
in the hospital and these you know and
rest is just like don't talk and he's
like flicks him off on the way out it
was just you did a lot of good stuff
yeah I mean when he starts to break down
because he he's finally showing his
family who he is yeah yeah instead of
saying because that was the problem with
him and his wife in his family was Oh
everything's fine right yeah i'll just
did hold everything in to myself right
and he had a moment I mean sadly it's
too late i mean his wife is married to
someone else oh yeah yeah and it's kids
are kind of you know not really in
content yeah so he's finally showing
some of his true self but right yeah a
little late but maybe maybe there's some
redemption in that and he can get closer
to them so yeah with a serial killers
house that was really creepy I mean
first of all he's married / having sex
with his half-sister right yeah who is
basic element like I'm [ __ ] and he
actually even though he comes off like
this hillbilly guy I'm gonna go to that
British accent I'm like wow I think he's
actually much more intelligent yeah and
then you think but his mind is so
twisted up yeah yeah he starts doing all
those different accents but I think he
has he is a much you know he can't be
doing all these serial killings and
getting away with it if he's just do
right yeah exactly but the house is
creepy as [ __ ] I mean all the like dolls
yeah it just looks so like a nasty
nastiest place on earth that like tub
full of I don't know what was like oh
yeah it's gross and then where they kept
the dead dad's body and you talk about
you haven't like planted the seed in me
in a wash some I don't know the flowers
like they are laid you're like oh yeah
yeah those rows and then we get to see
Carcosa finally yes you know and it's
like these empty ruins in a sense I
don't know exactly what they are yeah I
think I mean on a real live i think it's
an old bunker i believe it's all bugger
but it was cool we got to see like the
always miniature you know those me
teacher stick figures and see it in full
size now you know the actual maze he was
going through and just kind of leading
and taunting matthew mcconaughey it's
almost in a way like like he was ready
for it to the guy children's like he was
ready for this this this confrontation
at the ends yeah he led them hit into
car code you can handle himself two
dudes throwing axes and everything is
like that it was tough it's tough to
fighting yeah and then almost killing
coal I thought Cole was dead that's a
brew me because he like like you know
just ripped into him and that was those
I was a rough scene yeah and then
McConaughey got away with his head butts
yo you gotta get head but always works
yeah works yeah and so and then I like
that heart came to the rescue in a way
and then Cole came to the rescue little
bromance at the end you know as good
those guys were there for each other and
again just kind of leading to that more
positive about guys soon be like so I
thought heart was dead but in the end
I'm sorry Russ cold rust cohle
McConaughey was dead but then in the end
you know it's it all works out for him
so kind of well as good as it can I mean
it's like those guys are gonna stick
together hopefully they're not gonna
abandon each other which is good yeah
there's a good little bromance there
yeah yes also it was actually good to
see that it was heart that kind of came
to realize the clue of how to find
childress Rex I was kind of made him
seem a little stupid compared to Russell
hippie he's a highly you know trained
like detective he's not I can't be
stupid but yeah those of that's his
moment to shine exactly just for the
most of the sears it's been cold like I
found this and this is that in time we
need to follow this lead and whatever
and it was actually heart right that
came up with the green ears thing and
then with it yeah the paint find the
pain that goes up into the woman yeah
that's what eventually led them right to
Carcosa I really like that we got to see
the serial killers perspective yeah for
the entire series we've always gotten
the perspective of either rust or or
heart and I like that we got to see the
weird and it's kind of sticking as it
was to see the serial killers
perspective to see his motivations you
know he was not so much a character like
a character you could relate to
obviously but more I think he was more
of like a representation of just sister
evil I mean no cuz it those that one
line he said you don't know what they've
done to me or something I mean he's just
like he's more of representation just
what evil is and also he he was affected
it was that whole like Colt that
ingrained a lot of these things in his
head kind of perverted his mind and
turned him into this shit'll kill his
dad was part of this as well but then
eventually he took down his dad and his
dad's like dead all chained up in there
yeah and so his mouth was sewn shut and
like the complete us in me wants to know
the whole story like I'm orange din with
the Senators and that big pass so guys
live in the mansion's like what's their
story like how do they contribute to
this but I know the story is not about
solving all the missions so that's
that's the thing is then you have these
other people who are upset about the
ending because they didn't solve all
these mysteries you know I I saw on that
was at our comments section or maybe it
was like comment section of an of a
different website where someone was
complaining about like well we didn't
you know we didn't find out about who
Maggie was married or not that was
Maggie is that wife's name yes yeah we
married right who is he married to right
who cares yeah it's not about Lena what
who that has nothing to do with the show
she married someone rich it's obvious
yeah she's doing well with money wise
anywhere yes I mean the show is about
these guys that's all the shows ever
been that the characters in the
periphery are there but not really
important Maggie in the end I love you
know Michelle Moynihan but she's not
really that important to the story at
the end at the end at the end it's rust
and it's and it's in it's a heart at the
end yeah and then a lot of the people
were complaining saying oh it should
have been a Woody Harrelson's character
or Matthew McConaughey's character
should have been the killer like why
that's what I'm saying is the show never
I think people read too much into the
show and they wanted it to have these
like twists and turns and all this stuff
like that and and this show wasn't that
there's crime fiction like that this
isn't that version of crime fiction no I
think because of all the crime fiction
shows out right now I think with broad
Church and the fall and all these shows
like you see
e there is a resolution to some degree
at the end there is they they find out
who the killer is if I don't everything
everything stalled everything goes back
to somewhat being normal but this is a
story about these two guys lives that
just happen to resolve revolve on a
murder but the murder isn't the primary
focus and also comes to a logical
conclusion hmm and it wasn't he now
someone else you know other people were
saying well it should have been like
heart and coal really the same person it
was a split personality it's like this
is I don't know inceptions I know
ideally dreaming is he not dreaming I
mean this is not inside people whine
like all these things they kind of
placed all their projections or what
they wanted this show to be and so some
people were disappointed i really like i
really like that's the toughest thing
with with shows it's something with
finales i didn't watch the lost finale
obviously haven't seen i only watched it
season two but lost Battlestar Galactica
Spartacus what game of thrones will
eventually be I think with the finales I
think we all have these and we I'm
guilty i'm sure it's under we all went
like have these ideas of what it should
be but it's really hard i think it's a
I'm never gonna tell anybody how to
watch TV cuz everybody watch TV
different ways and watch TV and movies
and everything the way you want to
that's your personal thing but try to
Booty watch I would always tell her I
like try to be open mind let the show do
something to you don't put like your
perceptions into it as much as you can
it's almost impossible not to do yeah I
mean but you know I mean I do it I do it
all the time I mean I was kind of
disappointed the BSG ending and the lost
ending you know there was some good
things about it was ultimately wasn't
totally satisfied with either one and
this show is not I mean it shows not so
unique it's like I think I don't want to
praise that I love to Detective I don't
replace it so much I'm like this is
great I mean they still had the same
tropes together car oh we don't have any
cell service oh it's like come on it's
like you know it's the same things you
see in every other cup but I mean the I
think what I'm gonna remember the most
what the show is just the the acting
just the performances of woody and
McConaughey tis how well they did to go
the show itself was shot well the
story's interesting but I mean I don't
know many if we're talking miniseries
talking anthologies I don't know if I
like it more than band of brothers much
much different show I was judicial on I
put it on that level I've got I've got
band of brothers generation kill and now
true detective on my mini series Hall of
Fame Hall of Fame
uh yeah and this is anything we can it's
the different sheets well it's also hard
to compare this to a regular TV show
because then people were saying well how
does it compare to something like
breaking bad you can't compare it
because ringing bad is is 5 season right
this is one season the story's done you
can't you know you can't really compare
I mean right man but the same time it's
it's it's a little different yeah and
there's there's been a lot of good shows
out like this I mean if you're I was
going to say if you're feeling avoid a
form and void no pun you know without
the episode after this like you know
look at broadchurch look at Hannibal
look at the fall on netflix I mean
there's so many serial killer dramas
that result revolve around a town a
people a group of people and how it
affects their lives there's a lot of
good chills like this out right now
what's a good it's a good project al a
killing is like not the quality of this
the killing a similar quality you know I
said Dennis I both made this comment top
of the lake has the same cinematographer
as true detectives beautifully shot shot
shot by Jane Campion who is a filmmaker
she makes movies typically just like
fukunaga typically works in the film
medium so it's yeah there's just a lot
of good shows like that i just bought
the Red Riding trilogy yeah blu-ray
gonna watch that it used to be on
Netflix but they took it off so I'm
going to watch that that's a UK serial
killers three movies three different
directors but it's supposed to be the
same story yeah Andrew Garfield Sean
Bean like a bunch of great UK actors in
it alright guys so that's what we
thought of the true detective finale
what did you guys think did you love it
did you hate it are you looking forward
to the next season and what do you want
for next season because I've obviously
same actors are not coming back the same
writer is I don't think the same
director is no so it's gonna be a
totally different story with no actors
they actually said that they're not
going to do one director again it's
gonna be multiple directors yeah
multiple director personally about hard
women and talking about the Vienna
sanitation system probably la I'm
assuming like the there's like these
cults and different weird conspiracies
of the transportation system around la
so it's probably be I mean it should be
good i'm glad to have some hopefully
some female leads yeah i don't know if
it's gonna be two families but i think
at least one
you m'lady someone is suggested maybe
cate blanchett Wow I mean you know
because she won the Oscar Matthew
McConaughey won the Oscar Oscars yeah
Oscar was right of course we don't love
to see that so yeah who do you guys want
to see in this next season and what do
you what do you think it's gonna be
about you buzz your comments below on
the website think you're calm on our
youtube page think Carol pro make sure
to subscribe to that those go show this
on Twitter you know let us know like
what were your conspiracy theories
anybody do any fan fiction what is your
car coast well hopefully don't think too
deeply that's what's too weird too weird
let us know what you think about all
that at think here i'm at griffin de and
we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook or calm / think hero fans and
make sure to LIKE that page and share
our video and you know check out we're
gonna have our game of Thrones video
coming soon and uh other shows are
recovering as well
you